[MUSIC PLAYING]
YOSHI TAMURA: All righty.
Good morning.
Welcome to IO310, Sandboxing
Your Containers With gVisor.
I know that the keynote
is still going on,
so thank you for coming
from the beginning,
so I'm very excited about that.
My name is Yoshi.
I'm product manager on
Google's Kubernetes Engine.
I mostly focus on the
multi-tenancy which
will include the Sandbox
in gVisor that we're
going to talk today, and
Hardware Accelerator,
which I gave a talk on
Tuesday about GPU and the one
that we launched called
TPU in Kubernetes Engine.
So a little bit different,
but that's what I do at work.
And we have Ian here.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah,
and I'm Ian Lewis.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
I focus on Kubernetes and on
extensibility and security
in Kubernetes.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank you.
All right, then
let's get started.
Well, I think it's getting
very, very obvious,
but containers are
really, really exploding,
and if I look back to kind of--
I'm a computer
geek, and I've been
looking into virtual machine
and all of the computer
technologies for
quite a bit of time.
It's so kind of impressive
to see where containers
and Kubernetes are today.
Google has been
investing in containers
for more than a decade--
really more than 10 years ago,
and it has been a core part
of how we run the service.
And nowadays we run more
than four billion containers
launching every week, and that's
a really, really huge number.
But when I look
back at the history
when Google started the
container effort in the Linux
community, it was more
like a technology.
And it was indeed used there.
But I think we all agree that
Docker container that came in
around 2013 provided
a huge value in terms
of developer experience.
So before, the container was
one way of doing the computer
isolation, but it became more
like tools and packaging--
how do you share it--
and that was actually
very impressive.
At that point I was
not working at Google,
but it was a very, very
phenomenal thing to happen.
Then Kubernetes came
into play, because Google
had the experience of running
the container in a large scale
and now people start
seeing container
rather than the technology
more like a tool to increase
productivity and portability.
Then this problem about how
do we deploy the container,
how do we run container scale,
became a much more important
and critical problem,
and that's exactly why we
open source Kubernetes today.
So like this quote that-- it's
so beautiful that Kubernetes
is the Linux of the cloud.
It's super impressive
and amazing
to kind of see now how
Kubernetes and the containers
are helping people's
day-to-day workflow
that we're seeing today.
Well then, however as many
kind of popular technologies,
security becomes
concerned, right?
If your technology your
product is not popular,
not many people are
using, then, well, you
can actually a little bit
lower the bar to security.
I will definitely still
advocate that secure should
be coming first, but in reality
if you're busy with something
it comes afterwards.
But apparently because
containers on Kubernetes
are so pervasive and
widespread, now the security's
become a real problem.
And in fact, people
who participated
though the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation folks did
this certain-- in
the survey, security
remains as the top
challenge above anything.
Literally 43% of the
respondents raised
that security is the top one.
And now there's, like, storage,
and monitoring, and networking.
If you look at
monitoring today, it's
one of the hot sessions
in this Google Next.
But still, I think the
security is the top one,
and then you have a
lot of sessions also
that has been happening
this Next, too.
So I will strongly recommend
that, in addition to this talk,
if you're interested
in Kubernetes,
I think a lot of talks
are going to happen today,
but for those that happened
yesterday and the day before,
I strongly recommend
to watch a video too
to augment the things that
we're going to talk about.
So because I mentioned
that Google runs containers
for a long time,
and that's true,
so I get a lot of
questions, like, OK,
so how are you guys handling
this isolation concerns
around containers.
And that's a very good question.
And I feel lucky to
be part of Google,
because I can actually ask the
same question to my colleagues
who are in this room.
So how are you guys running?
How are you guys
dealing with this?
And not only the
product or project,
but I can also listen to a lot
of behind the scenes stories
there.
And hopefully this could be
kind of interesting for you.
So there's a very, very
long history-- like I said,
like more than 10 years
ago-- so a long history
of really iterating,
trying, and failing,
but exploring the best
way to run application
with the proper isolation.
So let's rewind the
clock a little bit
and see what we have
done in the past.
So take one, run as root.
This is a very bold statement.
I still feel kind of
nervous to say so.
I checked with my tech
leads a couple of times.
Is this real?
Like, did you really,
guys, run things at root?
And the answer was yes.
And apparently nothing
shields the system.
Your process can basically
access all devices there.
Of course, you can
access the whole file--
the host file system.
All resources available for you.
You can configure the
network as you like,
and you can perform any
system calls, of course.
And even you can send
sick kill to others.
So it's pretty, pretty--
I mean, when I heard
about this, I just went,
like, I'm pretty impressed
in a different way.
And of course what
if it goes wrong?
Of course, right?
And this rm, rf, and star--
still this kind of a
sequence of characters
make me nervous, right?
I'm pretty sure that
everyone in this room
has kind of
experienced this once
or twice in their whole
career and kind of regret it.
Your data is gone of course.
But more seriously,
that missed operation
is a real thing, but more into
it from a security context,
what if the malicious software
took advantage of this?
And basically there's no answer.
So take two.
Run as unprivileged user.
Right, yeah, this you
should do by default.
So basically give away
the privilege of root.
You don't need it.
You have only limited
access to those devices,
including network devices.
File system, of course,
will be limited,
and what kind of
system calls that you
can call will be also
checked, and blocked if not.
And also the sending
a signal capability
will be also limited.
So great, all
right, good enough.
But what if the process
can have a capability
to set the PID, or you
could create a raw socket.
You know, you can still
do something there.
So now take three.
Dropping capabilities.
Linux has a function
called capabilities,
which would split the
capabilities of that as
aggregated to root into
a much more finer ring.
You know, basically
with fewer capabilities
than basically you have
a better isolation there.
So for example, like
loading a kernel module,
which is apparently a big thing,
admin capability, capability
to setting the system
clock, and networking,
and the list goes
on and on and on.
So, OK, now we have
the capability,
so we somehow manage to
set what a process can do,
and what a process cannot do.
Well what if a process can
consume all the resources?
What about the
resource isolation?
We don't have anything.
So take four.
Cgroups.
So to address the resource
isolation problem,
Google has in the past
contributed this control group,
which will allow
limiting the resources
and accounting them
for better isolation.
For example, it will
limit access to the CPUs,
and it will also account the CPU
usage by the particular cgroup.
And same for a limit, and
account for the memory usage.
You could even assign
cores and memories--
memory nodes-- to
any particular group,
and also you can also control
the access to the device
based on which cgroup
that you're in.
Great, now we figured out
what the process can do when
your resources will be limited.
But still, a process
can see others.
It can still see what
others are doing.
Take five.
Namespace.
I actually didn't know,
but namespace actually
existed a long time ago.
And yesterday I was
looking into it.
And in past, when the
cgroup was proposed,
this integration with namespace
happened at that time.
So namespace
basically provides you
that visibility-- that isolation
for each namesake's type.
And for example,
like the networking,
PID, mount point, user,
IPC, a lot of things.
So with this namespace and
also the resource limitation,
your resource
isolation with cgroups,
it's a huge improvement.
I think it took quite a bit.
Like, I'm pretty sure it was
like two or three years when
I started seeing the proposal
from Google back in 2007-ish,
I think.
So it's a huge, huge
improvement compared
to what Linux was at that time.
I'm not sure how it's
doing today, but you know,
the original concept was
more from the [INAUDIBLE],,
but I was always told that Linux
doesn't have that capability.
But at this point I think it
was very clear that now there
was a so-called container
capability inside Linux,
so it was great.
And I hope I'm done with talking
about this, but life is unfair.
Someone said a very
inconvenient truth.
Containers do not contain.
It's a very short
word, but it's so true.
It points out the
fundamental part
that we all kind talk about.
The statement is
really so powerful
that it reveals a fundamental
challenge about isolating
processes in containers.
But you might ask--
I think I also wasn't paying so
much attention until I realized
this point, but OK, but you
have some sort of isolation
from a visibility capability
and resource consumption.
Why are we so focused about
these containers not contain?
And I think it's
a good question.
So we're focused
about on containers
not to contain because
what we're discussing here
is about the threats from the
inside of those containers.
And that would, then,
like this picture--
we're assuming this cute
cat is the attacker,
and the victim are
the parrots there.
Anyone wonder, who actually
put that cat inside the cage?
Who actually put a threat
inside a container?
And yes, understanding
that threat model
is very, very important.
There are two major cases.
I mean, I think there are
more detailed cases, but just
very roughly, two types.
One is, if you're
running a service that
allows users to submit code,
like SAAS and multi-tenancy,
like for us perhaps a Google App
Engine could be a good example.
A very obvious case I
think that I'm aware of,
if you're running a
WordPress and perhaps
allow users to use
their favorite plug-in,
or their own customized
plug-in and there you go.
You have a code that you
haven't been able to certify,
and that's when one
particular problem--
a particular case-- that
it could actually put
the threat inside your system.
The one which is somewhat
relevant is a security breach.
Yes, attack.
First of all, like a
firewall and everything,
you would want to first
prevent any threat coming
into your system.
However, we all know
that we do our best,
but something happened.
So once that incident
happens, the biggest principle
that we have any Google
in terms of security
is that we have to have
multiple layers of security.
So if you only have one bar,
then that's compromised,
and then it gets in, then
your entire system is at risk.
So then if you have
an attacker coming
into one of your
containers, if you
don't have anything
protecting or containing
inside at that point, then
all of the sudden one attack
could affect the rest.
So those are things that
we wanted to be careful.
And especially the latter case.
If you're running a system for
a larger organization, right?
If you have a full control
over what kind of code you go,
I think your chances of getting
to the problem is lowered,
but if you have a much
more distributed team
with a lot of different
kind of background
then you may or may not be
able to control that fully.
So if you want to be--
if your want more scale or
agility, than you actually
might want to think
about really containers
to contain the threat inside.
So when we talk about the threat
from the inside, what we're
talking about is we're talking
about attack through the Linux
kernel, which will allow these
containers to escape outside
of the isolation that
we talked earlier.
They usually exploit bugs inside
a Linux kernel through a system
service, like the obvious
one, system calls,
but like /proc files, and to
bypass all the long history
of the addin mechanism inside
this kernel and bypass that,
and eventually
elevate the privilege.
So escape and then attack
the kernel, and then break it
and take the privilege
of the system.
So this is the kind of very
high level, it's more detailed,
but that is the overall picture
of the threat at that time
that we're talking about.
So Linux kernel.
You may not notice because
it's so widely used,
and indeed it's great.
It's a lot of people paying
attention to security.
But reality is that it
has a huge attack surface.
Just by numbers, there are more
than 300 system calls there.
There are more than 2,000
CVs reported since 1999, out
of which more in 200 are
previous escalations.
So I'm not trying to
actually really criticize
about Linux kernel.
Like I mentioned earlier,
if your project product
code gets popular, then
two things happen, right?
You add more features
that you have
to respond to more of
those and functionality.
Then the system gets
complex, and then
if you get more popularity than
you have chances of attackers
paying attention to attack
the product or project,
because more audience
and they want
it to be more effective when
they think about the attack.
One of the most
famous ones, I think,
of that pattern of
attack is Dirty COW.
That happened to
a report in 2016.
It's a privilege escalation of
vulnerability inside a Linux
kernel.
An unprivileged local user
could exploit a race condition
the Copy On Write--
so therefore COW--
mechanism in the
Linux kernel subsystem
to increase their
privilege on the system.
So honestly, I was already
at Google, working at Google,
and I was always arguing about,
so what is the right isolation
for containers.
And I was more in the
camp of, well, containers
should be doing very well.
If you [INAUDIBLE] Linux,
and if you have these runs,
it should be good.
But this Dirty COW came up.
And it was a different
security team,
but they mentioned that,
yeah, there was Dirty COW,
and this one happened, and then
really opened up my eyes that,
OK, so if it's a complex
system then literally
we have to be prepared for
an unexpected situation.
So to be fair, there
are tools for experts.
I'll see why I say experts, but
one is SELinux, and AppArmor,
and more, based on a Linux
security module, which
is mandatory access
control which
provides fine-grain access
control per process.
So really you can describe
very well what a process can do
and cannot do.
The second one, Seccomp BPF.
Seccomp is short for a Secure
Computing Mode inside Linux,
and this dash BPF-- the
Berkeley Packet Filter--
is a filler by itself, but
what it means by the second BPF
is that you can actually
specify the policy
by using language
coming with the BPF,
and apply it to Seccomp.
And in an extension
of that, you can
define which syscall should be
filtered with the BPF rules.
Just to kind of gave
an example, before
coming to Kubernetes
Engine Team,
I worked at Chrome Webs
Team, and I actually
did bring Android
apps to Chrome Webs.
So I had the luck to look into
both Chrome Webs and Android
at same time.
And it's interesting
to me, because Android
used SELinux intensively,
and the Chrome Webs
used Seccomps intensively.
What it means is
SELinux in Android,
working app compatibility
is very important.
So you actually want to
have why syscall to cover,
or the framework to cover.
Therefore, you need to harden
the Linux kernel very strictly.
And they even have a test
suite and also the policy
that you have to get certified
to be named as Android.
On the other hand,
Chrome Webs, they're
using Seccomp BPF to sandbox
their Chrome browser rendering.
And the philosophy there is
to reduce the attack surface,
because there's only browser.
The browser is in the
application framework,
so all you want it to focus
is what the browser is
going to send to this system.
So, yeah, we have a system.
And the question is,
are these tools for me?
Maybe for you.
If you do know the
policy very well,
if you know what application
you want to pair-- like I said,
in the case of Chrome,
it's just a browser.
If you know, then it's great.
But the problem is
that the more detail
you describe in a policy,
the chances of that policy
to be generic for
any other process
will be lower, because
it's very specific.
So first of all, your app may
not run with those policies.
So isolation-wise
we have another one
called making a VN as isolation
boundary, which is true.
But then the downside
there is that, well,
you have to launch VN, and
then you have to run a kernel--
large or small, it's
still a kernel--
for just one container
or one process.
It's not necessarily
effective or elastic
as a regular process.
So OK, so we talk
about various things.
There are some pros and cons.
So what do you think?
Do we have all the
right tools for us?
What do you want?
IAN LEWIS: Right.
So at Google, we looked at a
number of different solutions.
We talked about, we looked
at things like Seccomp,
we look at things like
SELinux and AppArmor,
we looked at things
like VM Solutions,
and there's trade-offs between
all of these different things.
And so the thing
that we saw that we
would have to make
trade-offs with
is that we wanted our
containers to be secure
so that attackers that have
gotten control of the container
can't break out
of the container.
We wanted something that was,
like, less configuration,
or ideally zero
configuration, something
that was kind of like
a self-driving car,
here, where it's kind of
turnkey solution-- something we
can just get in and go.
We don't have to
configure per application,
you know, filters, or like per
application rights, some sort
of SE Linux or AppArmor policy.
We want to just be able to run
our applications unmodified.
Another was that
we wanted to have
something that was lightweight.
We ran a lot of
containers, and so we
wanted something that
gave a similar experience
to what we were used to.
So we want something
that's lightweight, doesn't
use a lot of resources,
and gives us lower load
memory and CPU overhead.
And so we looked
at these, and we
saw that we had to make
a lot of trade-offs,
but we thought what if we didn't
have to make these trade-offs.
What if we could get everything
we wanted in a system?
We could maybe make
different trade-offs
and then get all of the
things that we wanted here.
And so we came up with
something called gVisor.
So gVisor is a sandbox
for containers,
and it implements a
independent user space kernel.
And so this runs in user space,
separate from the Linux kernel,
so it gives you an extra
level of isolation.
And so as we were doing
this, we're like, you know,
the Linux system call interface
is like this wide attack
surface.
But you can think of
it kind of like an API.
The Linux kernel
provides you an API
that your applications then use
to execute themselves and get
resources, so what
if we just made
a different implementation
of that API,
and we ran that in userspace?
And that's how we came up
with the idea for gVisor.
And so it's a user
space kernel that
implements these system calls.
So it's similar to something
like user space Linux,
except we have our own kernel
rather than trying to run Linux
itself in user space.
And so this gives us the kind
of high security that we want.
It's a user space kernel that
implements these syscalls,
and it's written in Go.
And the reason why
we did it in Go
is because we got
a good trade-offs
when using Go between the memory
and type safety of the language
runtime, as well as the speed.
And we also get this kind
of Linux user space kernel,
so that even if the attacker
gets control of the container
application, then they find
some sort of bug in the gVisor,
even if they do that
they still don't
have control of the system.
They're still stuck
in user space,
so they can't just execute
everything as the kernel
and get full access
to the whole host.
gVisor is also zero config.
We can run unmodified
Linux applications
because we implement
the Linux syscalls.
Applications can-- we can
just run them in the sandbox,
and have them use that kernel.
And so we don't need to write
any filters or profiles--
like security profiles,
things like that-- in order
to get the lease privilege
for our applications.
Typically for those
type of filters,
you would need to know
what the application needs
to use, what
capabilities it needs,
what syscalls it's using,
and what sort of resources
it needs from the
operating system
in order to actually
configure your lease
privilege for the application.
But with gVisor, we can just run
the application in the sandbox
and we don't need to do
these kind of configurations.
It's also very light and quick.
So it's very similar to
the kind of experience
that we got when running
normal containers.
So we have basically a
15-megabyte or so memory
footprint.
This can kind of change
depending on the application
and how it actually uses
the gVisor userspace kernel.
But in general you get something
around a 15-megabyte memory
footprint.
So you get just that
amount of overhead,
and also you can
start up applications
in around 150 milliseconds.
So this is very similar to the
way that the containers run.
We don't have to have
a lot of startup time
or a lot of overhead
associated with our sandbox.
So this really fit well
with our kind of model,
and fit well with our container
orchestration within Google.
And so we use gVisor for a
number of things within Google,
but one of the more
obvious things--
like Yoshi mentioned--
and this is a tweet
from our director, Oren.
We use it within cloud
platform particularly
for things where users need
to upload application code,
and we run it on their behalf.
So we don't want to have
a situation where somebody
can upload code and then get
access to somebody else's
application, or break
out of a container
and then read some
other user's data.
That would be a pretty
bad security breach.
So what we want is
to provide a sandbox
to run these applications.
And so for things like App
Engine, Cloud Functions,
and Cloud ML.
This is a perfect
fit for us in order
to run applications within
a sandbox like this.
And then we decided that this
was a particularly interesting
technology, and
this is something
that, now that
containers are becoming
more ubiquitous
and more popular,
and things like orchestration
systems like Kubernetes
are starting to become popular,
and people are starting
to build passes, and all kinds
of different systems on top,
we thought that gVisor
would be something
that users outside
of Google could
take advantage of
in order to provide
these type of solutions.
And so we open sourced
it, and now it's
on GitHub at
GitHub/Google/gVisor.
We open sourced it in
May this year at KubeCon,
and the response was enormous.
Like, it was quite a lot
more than we expected.
Within 10 days we had
5,000 GitHub stars,
and we have over 6,400 today.
So thanks to all of you who
have started us on GitHub
and who are kind of
following a project.
But the response
has been enormous,
and we're really
kind of interested
in how we can take this
further and integrate this
with Kubernetes and other
orchestration systems.
But before we do that,
let's take a look back
at the actual architecture,
and dive a little bit deeper
into the architecture of gVisor.
So gVisor is a system
for running a sandbox.
And so we have our
user space kernel,
but we wanted to make something
that made it easy for folks
to run in containers
in our sandbox.
And so we provide an
OCI-compatible interface.
So if you're a
Docker user you may
be familiar with runc, which is
the OCI runtime for containers.
And gVisor provides a
command called runsc
that is essentially a
drop-in replacement for runc,
and provides this
OCI implementation.
So we can run OCI bundles
for containers in a sandbox
very easily.
And so once you
start up a container,
that container's application
is loaded into memory
along with the sentry, which
is our kernel in userspace.
And the application is loaded
into the sentry's user memory.
And then the
application is executed.
But as we are
executing it the sentry
has two different
types of modes.
One is a KVM mode, and
one is a ptrace mode.
And what these do is these
intercept the syscalls
that the application makes
and then handles them
inside the sentry-- so inside
of the userspace kernel.
So we don't actually
go into the kernel
in order to handle a lot of
the syscalls that we're making.
The sentry does
actually have to make
a few syscalls to the
Linux kernel itself,
but that surface area
is highly reduced
compared to a normal container.
So Yoshi mentioned that
we had 319 total syscalls
for the Linux syscall API, and
the sentry narrows that down
to a surface area of
something along the lines
of between 10 and 20.
So something like that.
And because we know
what the sentry needs
in terms of its own syscalls,
we can then put a satcom profile
on that and further lock down
so that only those syscalls are
the ones that can actually
be run by the sentry.
And so even if somebody
is able to take control
of an application and then
they find some sort of bug
in the sentry-- some sort of
buffer overrun or something
like that-- that they're able
to execute code as the sentry,
they're still locked into
this userspace sandbox.
They can only run
a few syscalls.
And so you're not actually
able to do anything
very much at that point.
The sandbox actually can't
even write to the file system.
When actually locations need
to write to the file system,
the sentry uses a
separate process
that we start up for the
container called a gofer.
And we use the 9P
protocol in order
to send our to do file I/O
and things like network I/O.
So that type of I/O
is not something
that you can actually do
just unlimited, even if you
can execute code as the sentry.
So this gives us a quite a
good sandbox for applications
to run for untrusted code.
It gives us a very good
isolation from the kernel.
But as we said, everything that
you do is trade-offs, right?
I said that earlier
that we didn't
want to make the
trade-offs between security
and zero config, and having
lightweight containers,
but that means that we
have to make trade-offs
in some other places.
And so there are
some things that we
have to add as caveats to
running things in gVisor.
Let's walk through some
of the applications that
might be impacted by
running in a gVisor sandbox.
The first of those is
syscall heavy workloads.
So because gVisor is
implementing these syscalls
in user space, it's a kernel
that's using the go runtime,
and just by the fact of
being running user space,
there is a slight
difference in things,
like running kernel
code is running
is a higher priority on on
the CPU, and things like that.
So you will get some
performance impact.
So applications
that might run lots
of syscalls in a
tight loop, those
are the types of
applications that
are going to be impacted
performance-wise
by running in gVisor.
There's also the idea of syscall
coverage and compatibility.
So gVisor itself implements
many of the Linux syscalls,
but it doesn't implement every
single last one of them--
at least not currently.
And so there's a total of 319,
but we implement around 211,
and those are some of the
more highly-used ones,
but it also means
that applications
that use those syscalls
that we don't implement
will have some
compatibility issues.
The last thing that I want
to highlight as a caveat
is direct access to hardware.
So applications that need
direct access to hardware
are potentially not a great
fit for gVisor, and partly
because just of the
nature of the fact
that we are running
in a sandbox.
Providing direct
access to hardware
from a security
standpoint is very risky
because you have direct
access to the hardware.
You can do whatever you want.
So if the application is
compromised the entire host
is generally compromised.
And so gVisor doesn't
have the concept
that a normal Linux kernel does
of device drivers and things
like that, and so direct
access to hardware
like GPUs or other
specialty hardware
may not be a good fit for
gVisor, at least not right now.
Great.
So that's out of the way.
Let's actually take a look at a
couple of the vulnerabilities.
The first one is a Dirty COW,
and the second one is Meltdown.
And we'll just
kind of take a look
at how gVisor might
mitigate a couple
of these vulnerabilities,
and explain what they do
and then how gVisor
kind of mitigates them.
Thank you.
All right.
So let's switch over
to the demo machine.
YOSHI TAMURA: Can we switch?
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, can we switch
over to the demo machine here?
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank you.
IAN LEWIS: All right, great.
Let's make this a
little bit bigger.
So what I'm going
to do here is, I'm
going to run an application
that makes use of the Dirty COW
exploit, and run this in
just a normal container
to show you what happens
when you do that.
So what happens here
is what I have here is
I have an OCI bundle.
So this is just a
regular container.
So you can think of this
as just a container that's
been unpacked, or a
container image that's
been unpacked to
the file system,
and we're going to
run this using runc.
So if we just do like an
n20 here with a config,
we can see we're going to
run an application here
inside the container,
we're going
to write some data
to the exec password.
We're running this as
a user, not as root.
So normally the user wouldn't
be able to write to this file.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to write this little
string here, spam,
into the exact password
file, which is not something
that you would
normally be able to do,
but because of Dirty COW
exploiting Dirty COW,
you're able to do that.
So when we run it inside
a normal container--
we're going to do sudo runc run.
We've to give it to me here.
We'll just say dirtycow.
So when we run this
application, what this is doing
is it's taking advantage of
a race condition in the Linux
kernel.
What this is doing is
doing a couple of syscalls
in two different threads
at the same time in kind
of a tight loop, and when
it gets to the kernel
state in just the right place,
it's able to write to a file
regardless of what permissions
are associated with that file.
And so what we're
doing here, this
uses two different syscalls.
One of them is the
madvise syscall
and one is a ptrace syscall.
But the madvise
syscall is one syscall
that is highly used in
normal applications.
So this is something that's
very hard to actually filter out
of an application.
So like, you know, you
can't necessarily just
put on a setcom policy that you
can't run madvise or something
like that, because
madvise is used
in pretty much every
application out there.
So even if you're able to know
what your application uses
for things like syscalls,
you're not always
able to just filter
out those calls.
Some of them you actually
need to be using.
OK, so here the
application's finished.
It's run through our
tight loop and has
been able to take
advantage of Dirty COW.
And so what we'll do here is
we'll take a look at the--
actually we need to look at
the root file system here.
And we'll look at the password
file, and scroll up here.
So we're actually able
see here that we've
written to the beginning
of this file, here.
So you can imagine
that we could overwrite
just lines in this file,
add a new root password,
and just get privilege
escalation that way.
So it's very easy to
get privilege escalation
when you can just write to
any file on the file system.
So this is something that's
really, really bad for us.
So let's switch over and take
a look at running it in gVisor.
So when we do this, we have
the exact same OCI bundle.
We're going to do a--
show you here, just the
exact same configuration.
We're running as the same user.
We're using the
same application.
We're going to write to the
same file with the same content,
but this time we're going
to use runsc gVisor.
So we're going to
do sudo, runsc.
I'm going to add a couple
of flags in here just
to show some debug
information to show you
what's going on, because
otherwise it would just kind
of sit here and run.
All right, so when
we run it in gVisor,
we're able to actually
run the application.
And the application executes
exactly the same way
as it would inside of a normal
container, except for what it's
doing here is it's running
in two different loops
or in two different threads
and executing madvise
and ptrace over and over again.
And so what this is doing
is just spitting out
logs every time the madvise
and ptrace are called.
But you can see here that
the application is actually
running, but in the
end we won't actually
be able to write to the file.
So we go in here, actually.
I should open up another SSH.
And we'll just look at
the file and then verify
that the file has not
actually been written to.
Let's do this, all
right, and then we
say root file system,
exec password.
So we look up here.
We can see that we
haven't actually
been able to write to this.
And by nature, this particular
attack-- the attacker
will just continue
to run and try
to take advantage of
the kernel, and as long
as it's not able to, it's just
not able to write to the file.
But it's also kind
of interesting
to note that this is exactly
the type of application that
can have a performance
impact in gVisor,
because it's running
in a tight loop
and just executing syscalls.
This is actually a worst
case scenario for that.
But normal applications aren't
doing this type of thing.
So we're able to see that we
can mitigate vulnerabilities
with, like, Dirty COW, and
that's a kind of a pure Linux
kernel vulnerability.
But what about for other
kinds of vulnerabilities?
So Meltdown is
another vulnerability
that's very popular.
And meltdown is a combination
of hardware vulnerability
as well as software
vulnerability,
so this is something that,
because gVisor is a software
sandbox we can't 100%
mitigate vulnerabilities,
but in some sense
on the software side
we can mitigate it a little bit.
So for instance, we are
going to run an application
and use Meltdown.
And what Meltdown
does is, it takes
advantage of a hardware bug in
kind of conditional execution.
But the most easy way to
take advantage of that
is in a situation where in
the past, when applications
were run they would map kernel
memory into the process itself.
And so if you do that and
you have this hardware bug,
you're very easily able
to have the application be
able to read that kernel
memory in any place--
and not just places that
you're able to read,
but ones that you
shouldn't be able to read.
So here what we're
going to do is
we're going to get the memory
address of the Linux prok
banner.
So this is something that's
part of kernel memory.
And so when an application
is run this kernel memory is
mapped in, and then what we're
going to do is we're going
to tell our application to read
this particular piece of kernel
memory-- this address
from kernel memory--
that it normally
shouldn't be able to read.
So we just look at this.
It's actually-- this is
just an address in memory
that we want to try to read.
So if we run this in a
normal Docker container--
So we're going to run this
in a normal Docker container
with runc, and we're
going to give it
the address that we
have here and have
it read out that memory.
So when we do that,
we're able to see
that the application
is vulnerable
and that we're able to
read out of the memory.
And the Linux prok
banner just has
some information about
the kernel version,
and some other information.
So that's not particularly bad.
But reading other
parts of kernel memory
could potentially give
you lots and lots-- like,
allow you to do lots of
different types of privilege
escalation.
So when we bring this
using the same way,
but we run it in
gVisor, gVisor actually
doesn't map in
this kernel memory,
and so we're able to
mitigate this slightly.
I didn't run this with sudo.
Oh no.
AUDIENCE: Put it
before the meltdown.
IAN LEWIS: Yes, you are right.
So we run this
with gVisor, we're
able to see that
it's not runnable.
And because the kernel memory
is not mapped into the process,
we're not able to actually
read that memory out
from Linux prok banner.
So in that sense, some things
can be partially mitigated.
There are other theoretical ways
that you could take advantage
of Meltdown in
gVisor, but those are
things that we think are a
little bit harder to actually
get working, because gVisor
has a hardend sandbox.
All right, great.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank you, Ian.
Then back to the slides please.
These is our probably
first time doing
the demonstration on stage.
So it was great to
actually see it in action.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
So gVisor and Kubernetes--
both were invented at
Google, and we democratized
that with open source--
both Kubernetes and gVisor.
And by the way,
gVisor, if you like
it there are a couple of
things you could do for us.
You could go to GitHub,
press star button.
You could Fork it.
We have our 300 Forks.
So if you have
interesting projects,
absolutely please Fork it.
We would love to hear
what it could do.
And also, perhaps
most importantly--
like Ian mentioned--
gVisor took a different
kind of trade-off,
which was Cisco compatibility.
If you can try running your
application and it didn't run,
file a bug, let us know, and
let us know your use case.
I think that's
what we would love
to know, just only with gVisor.
But we wanted to make this
gVisor accessible to everybody
through Kubernetes.
We're leading the effort on
introducing the concept called
sandbox pause specification
in the Kubernetes community
right now.
And of course, gVisor
is one with the runtimes
that have been proposed for a
sandbox pause in Kubernetes.
What it means is that,
well, Ian is a great hacker,
so he can type in
a command nicely,
but want to make
it more generic.
Meaning, if we could
actually let people access
use gVisor through
Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE],,
how wonderful that could be.
And I'm going to quickly
talk about what we're doing
in the community as we speak.
So sandboxing Kubernetes-- it's
not done yet, unfortunately.
It would be great to finish up
and talk while, and yeah, we're
done, but it's just a
work in progress really.
Work in progress, but it
doesn't mean that we're
making things inside Google.
We're really doing just
everything in open source.
So if you look at all the
open source discussion,
you'll see Tim Allclair, our
tech lead for this project,
and he's making huge progress.
So the sandbox pods--
so new Kubernetes API for the
sandbox containers were pods.
It will be a
pod-level isolation.
So for people who don't know
what the definition between pod
and container-- well,
it's kind of similar.
But pod is the
smallest granularity
on the perimeter that could
be scheduled by Kubernetes.
And inside a pod, you could
have multiple containers.
So it will protect this
group of containers.
That's a pod.
We hope that for anything that's
going to be part of the sandbox
pod we'll have at least two,
but multiple layers of isolation
boundaries, because otherwise
it doesn't make so much sense
to call this a sandbox pod.
If you could break out,
what's the difference?
This is the really
work-in-progress API.
I have more detail, but I just
decided not to put too much.
This is actually
the third version.
When I started
working on the slide,
this was the third
version I had changed,
so as we speak
we're making change.
But I think Tim
already has the very
close to final form as
a submission, so we'll
see how that lands in the
future version of Kubernetes.
So just to kind of
give you a sneak peek,
runtime class is a new API to
specify the runtime, meaning
which runtime that I want to
use for my pod and containers.
You can specify which runtime
class to use from the pod spec.
So Tim emphasized
that, make it--
V1 alpha is very clear.
Yes, it's still working on it.
So the name will be runtime
class, and in this case
metadata name will be
gVisor, and a runtime handler
will specify another gVisor,
what's another thing.
And inside there,
it goes by which
file of the runtime to use and
all the relevant specification.
But that's something that
we believe that the cluster
operator-- so if you're
running on premises,
the cluster admin will be in
charge for setting that up.
And in case of cloud,
it will probably
be us, like cloud
operator providers
will be configuring the left
side of the configuration.
And all users have to do is to
write up a regular pod spec,
specify in the spec that you're
specifying runtime class name,
and choose whatever you want to.
We talked about gVisor
today, but there are also
other approaches, like
others containers.
So we're working together to
standardize this specification.
I think we're making
huge progress there.
So today we talked about
the containerisation
from the past and the present.
The past is, like, iteration,
and the present is what we have
open source-- what we
have in Kubernetes--
Kubernetes and gVisor.
And of course we just talked
a little bit of the future
to bring it together.
So if you're interested
in gVisor or running
gVisor with Kubernetes
engine, please let us know.
We would love to hear
your thoughts there.
So this is a link to our forum.
We'd love to continue the
discussion in a conversation.
Thank you.
We ran out of time, So hopefully
we could take questions
after that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]